Film Courage: With your screenwriting Van
do you try to be original or do you try to
give the audience what you think they would
want?
Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker/Photographer: I
think I try to come up the original concept
and you want to start out with that because
that’s sort of what drives you.
I know they say hey think about the audience,
what's your genre, who's watching this?
I think you start writing the story that motivates
you and what gets you through because you're
going to have to live with this for a long
time in terms of producing it or in terms
of writing it and then if you go on to try
to get it produced and made it has to be something
that that that you're proud of or that you
want to you know go through that journey with
so if that idea is an original idea for you
and at least it's for me I start with that
so the scripts that I have on written is is
is basically from original thoughts and not
I don't even think about the budget and stuff
like that maybe because the stories I write
just tend to you know fall in the same thing
but you know it's not super high concept it's
not out in space it's not this it's just like
grounded in in what's happening here in humanity
but but when I start out something like I
come it from a original perspective do you
think you could be okay with being a writer
for hire or something where it may not be
your style and maybe two hand-holding of a
of a story but you're being sort of like okay
paid to do it even though it might not be
something you would want to watch would you
have trouble with that this is like me going
through like if I'm actually writing sticking
to the themes my original thought of all this
was to have a sustainable career so to answer
that yeah I would do it I'm not a young buck
coming out at 25 years old and having the
luxury of a lot of time time and doing this
but I think the more you can do anything the
better you get get at it you know you know
you always hear now I start to understand
why people might complain why actors take
certain roles and things like that you know
no one can everyone can't be daniel day-lewis
and do these maybe you just want to be a role
that's goofy and fun maybe I want to test
my chops on something different from I'm not
you know we talked about athletes and stuff
you want to come back to each season with
new things that you learn everything you know
whether if I ever get a chance at a studio
world writing something that's you know that
I'm going to learn something from that you
could always take that back and then I could
always do it as a hobby my own stuff later
you know that kind of stuff so things like
that I'm still not opposed to that if if that
is an opportunity or you know I'm not one
of those I'm going to be not tour and everything
that's going to happen I'm just trying to
take it one one film at a time if it happens
the they'll be I think that would be a good
problem to have to make that decision I always
wonder about like actors who get these commercials
where they become these spokespersons for
like well over a decade and and how do they
feel about that I mean if it provides a nice
lifestyle for someone and they feel a sense
of satisfaction maybe they weren't the leading
role on general hospital or something but
you know it's always but then some people
go to the sellout term and I think that would
be I think most of us would probably they'd
go with the steady paycheck yeah you know
we think percentage-wise of things and me
you want you know how many like you said how
many of us can can be paul thomas anderson
or quentin tarantino how how many people are
even behind the scenes doing stuff that we
don't even know about that no one does that
has to punch up a script or do this or do
whatever you ha you have but if you're in
in it it it beats other things so like you
know you know definitely it would be something
it's now it's not like something you always
want to do and like you want to build leverage
but also you want to be working you know nothing
wrong with them no no no no not that how has
All Roads To Pearla changed your writing process
I think since it's one of the earlier ones
and and and and seeing how it could be developed
and into it I think now I'm trying to get
tighter in my storytelling you know you're
trying to if again back to an athlete analogy
an athlete what could you work on I think
it's for writing for film I need to be tighter
for 90 minutes for hours to Pearla and other
things I think there's a world where you can
have it like episodic limited series so you
could go dive into the characters more you
know and I think that's that's what i've kind
of learned if I have a if I have a situation
or an idea that involves tons of characters
I probably would start out writing it as a
pilot and now if I have like a pretty great
idea that I could tell within a film space
of like 90 minutes i'll switch to film I think
that's that's how riding that all roads superior
has helped me kind of kind of divide the two
areas I believe just to keep them separate
because each one has its own sort of you know
format and and expectations when you say tighter
do you mean that you feel sometimes the story
will meander and you're trying to keep it
on course yeah yeah I think for me personally
I think because I write very visually I think
it's too flowery and I write as a writer director
so there's a lot of things I'm putting on
the page that that I don't need to because
I know I'm going to direct it but I like to
write it and create it for for folks but if
I was purely writing as a writer I get a lot
tighter because I want to experience that
in terms of like not to be you know to explain
things and not have as much you know camera
direction or setting things up and flowery
I want it tighter so I won't so I could turn
the page that would be my goal now before
I think the goal before was writing something
with with heart now I think maintaining that
but but condensed yeah.
Question For The Viewers:
What did you like about this video?